the Johnson government has hardly
covered itself in Moses since Boris
became Prime Minister but in one
interview at least it's done exactly the
right thing in changing the may
administration's narrow-minded attitude
to foreign students studying in Britain
by giving them longer visas after
completing their university courses its
mechanized how important attractive
foreign students is to this country both
economically and culturally there are
more than 400,000 foreign students
studying in Britain bringing in a
massive twenty billion pounds a year in
foreign exchange it is in effect a major
export business but it also has the
advantage of selling the benefits of
Britain to generations of overseas
students most of whom go back home
enthusiastic about our country and of
course the fees they pay also allow our
universities to expand and help pay for
British students that mrs. May couldn't
see this tells you a lot about her
limited view of the world and how
obsessed she was about immigration
figures so in this area alone well done
Belize yeah here Greg I'm here
completely endorsed what you've said as
a former international student myself as
the third generation and my family on
both sides both my grandfather's my
mother are all educated here and in
Britain are my own children at British
universities this is great news but
before I make more of my argument let's
hear from Vivian Stern the director of
Universities UK international and this
is what she had to say we've certainly
seen some countries who have been
effectively put off coming to study in
the UK as a result of a slightly more
restrictive policy introduced in 2012 so
places like India particularly we saw
and having of the number of Indian
students who chose to come and study in
the UK that's now going to bounce back
and that would be great for us when you
think about how important India is going
to be in this coming century so it's a
really welcome change in direction and
we're going to see
the results of that I think quite
quickly the irony of all this is that in
2007 I actually spearheaded in the House
of Lords with cross-party support the
bringing in of the two-year post
graduation work visa and the government
listened up and it was bought in 2008
and then Theresa May when she was Home
Secretary in 2012 it was removed and for
seven years we went crying out to
government please bring this back why
well international students pay pretty
huge fees and living expenses to be here
those two years extra give them the
opportunity to work to get some work
experience to earn some money to help
pay for their education and while doing
that they're helping our companies and
contributing to our economy we have the
lowest level of unemployment in over 40
years and here we have international
students helping the the brightest
they're great they're capable the next
thing is they're paying taxes so they
contribute to our Exchequer the next
thing is they build the bridges that
they built through being at university
with by working over here and they go
back to their countries as ambassadors
for our country forever and when they
want to do business with any country
afterwards which country they're gonna
think of first the UK there are more
world leaders right today as we speak
almost 60 who educated British
universities along with American
universities than any other countries in
the world and so this is one of our
strongest elements of soft power that we
have so this is not just a win-win
situation this is a win-win-win today it
sounds like great news the brightest and
the best from around the world come here
they study they work they stay on the
enrich our country and our culture and I
have a couple of reservation this is one
there is no cap on the numbers who can
come here so so how where are all these
graduates gonna live now and the thing
you were talking about missus Mays moved
before migration watch have already
pointed out they're saying that this is
a retrograde step and it's likely to
lead to the situation we had before
where students were coming here
pretending to study and rolling in an
institution and not studying going to
work stacking shelves in sales bees so
so that will nowhere so what so what I
think has to be done is that study visa
can't be used as a backdoor route to
mess of bread to controls and
the thing is universities that the
applications of foreign students to
universities is that record levels at
the moment and and so so what migration
what you're saying is why why do value a
study visa if you could adjust contracts
very quickly family goals this is
absolute nonsense do you know we are
competing migration watches argument
we're competing with the rest of the
world the migration Advisory Committee
commissioned by the Home Office
themselves said in their report the
number one reason that foreign students
do not choose the UK as the number one
choice is the lack of post study work
opportunities you get two or three years
in Canada we should be saying is when I
mean I just your Chancellor bugling I
was chancellor at the University of York
for 11 years and in my graduation
species at the end in the last few years
I used to think I do that I used to
thank the foreign students they're
choosing to come to Britain and choosing
to come to your this is this is a win
win and yet here we were and yet I felt
that they were thought well we're here
under you know we're here and from
government that doesn't really want us
I'm gonna be really brief because I
think I totally agree with you I think
this and you I think this is a great
British success story I hear your
reservations and I'm sorry i discount
them but actually there's someone we
should be talking about this which is
related to you something in fact it's
your brothers and joe johnson who made
this like a personal crusade credit to
him why did he feel it so keenly he
tried to persuade when he was a number
had a number ten policy unit he tried to
persuade his men in the home office that
it was absolutely insane to have
students in the net immigration figures
and they should be removed because you
know they they are an absent we've
talked about what a win-win when they
are plus they pay up to sixty thousand
pounds in fees whereas UK students pay
nine thousand so you know on every score
it's a tick and and but she dug in
because they it became an article of
faith that immigration had to be reduced
to tens of thousands and it was she felt
it when she denied in fact it was a fail
you mentioned her let's let's hear what
she says she says it has become very
apparent that the old student visa
regime failed to control immigration the
changes refocus the student route as a
everyone available only to the brightest
and the best the new system is designed
to ensure students come for a limited
period to study not to work and make a
positive contribution while they are
here you know we know why she did what
she did because it was big that's that
system the previous system was being
abused can I just say that there was a
stage when there were a whole load of
bogus colleges they were all shut down
that's criminal this is does not apply
to our universities and you know what
after she said this after she said this
they did an analysis just within the
last two years and they found that less
than five thousand less than five
thousand not a hundred thousand a year
international students overstay the vast
majority go back to their countries or
get a proper job over here so there is
this is a complete misnomer and if you
pull the public the public
overwhelmingly have no objection to
international students staying on and
working after their studies and I think
I think your brother's policy sort of
advocates the fact that there is a way
of checking what the students are doing
they have to be they're going to be
checked on to make sure they are studied
in proper institutions which i think is
fair but surely the real problem was
that the government had committed itself
to reducing immigration and continued to
keep foreign students in the immigration
yeah there was no one in the cabinet
supporting it apart from mrs. maybe now
the government wants to remove this net
migration target which is absolutely
ludicrous they've never hit it and I
want to say thank you to your brother
Joe and I won't say thank you to your
brother Boris on this count well down to
the government